hey richard adam my name is mark i'm
from germany
i'm a nutritionist an athlete an
environmentalist and of course
100 plant-based or inspired by your
podcast rich
my question has to do with the climate
emergency we find ourselves in i already
imposed a lot of restrictions upon
myself
like choosing my bike instead of my car
reducing the amount of plastic i buy
increasing the amount of local and
caesar fruits and vegetables
not taking planes and many things more
and these restrictions have actually
improved my quality of life especially
the plastic diet
however i'm also struggling to choose
between what is unnecessary and should
thus be restricted
and what is still acceptable like using
the car for holiday
creating carbon emissions by watching
netflix or living
in a beautiful but huge house instead of
a more minimalistic and environmentally
friendly alternative
i'm trying to figure out the right spot
between tom hanks and castaway and
leonardo dicaprio in the world of wall
street thanks guys
um thank you for the question mark
that's a great question
uh it sounds like he's he's more tom
hanks in castaway than he is leonardo
dicaprio and
wolf of wall street yes by a country
mile
um this is the dilemma that we're all
struggling with is it not and i think um
there are things that we can do
which you are already doing and i
applaud you for that
and i'm trying to do the same
at the same time i think we need to like
acknowledge and just recognize
that that none of us are are living you
know a completely carbon neutral
lifestyle like we are consumptive beings
living in the material world on planet
earth
we have an aspiration to live more
gently
on the planet to live more in alignment
with the rhythms
of what serves the ecosystem
that we all share but none of us are
immune from
the harms that just our existence
creates
and i don't think that anybody is served
by somebody becoming you know a complete
martyr or a recluse i think that we do
what we can
and we always strive to be better if we
can you know
the more carbon neutral we can become
the less that we get on airplanes the
less
uh you know um petrochemicals that we're
using all of these things are
are great but i think where we have to
think about how can we
leverage this message to create a ripple
effect with other people
right so if everybody reduced their
carbon footprint 10 that would be
massive and more impactful than you
living in you know an electric van down
by the river and never communicating
with anyone you know what i mean
so it goes back to
what we were talking about at the outset
of this podcast which is that meaningful
conversation matters so i think
uh where you can create leverage
is to engage your community with these
ideas
to try to spread them and what i found
and everybody has their own personal
strategy for how they communicate and
share ideas
i found that that what seems to work
really well
is to make these lifestyle choices seem
fun and cool like they're not the
purview
of an antiquated class of people that
you can't connect with but they're
actually
awesome you know and and we can thrive
and live and be happy and
fulfilled and connected in a way that
perhaps eludes us
in our modern world by adopting some of
these habits and practices so
i think it's i think that the evolution
for you
is not to you know become tom hanks and
castaway
but to try to be uh you know a
a lighthouse and to be an example
of some of these lifestyle principles um
within your community because we live in
the world
right you're not you're not a monk
meditating in the cave
right you're a spiritual being having a
human experience
in the midst of a lot of chaos and
disruption
so how can you be
a force for positive change among those
people that you're connected with
i like that i mean i think uh first of
all
it's very funny and witty ending to the
question um
but i'm pretty sure that tom hanks
didn't want to be the guy in castaway
i remember that movie but yeah i mean i
think
um we make choices to live our lives
because we
like you know like the fact that you've
had positive
reinforcement from the lifestyle choices
you've made
um shows that it you did it for you as
well as for any any other reason
you know you yes you're limiting your
emissions you're limiting your impact
and that's a great thing but that's a
great thing for you as well as for
the world and that's great i mean that's
i think that's the ideal right
that you that that's the kind of balance
that we want to strike where we're
feeling like we're living our truth
and we're feeling good living our truth
and we're actually feeling better than
we did when we weren't
and some of it is like so-called
restrictions have actually ended up
being
beneficial to us personally i think
that's great i think it's amazing that
you've done that
um and uh but i agree i think there's
also
fixes you can do if you if you live in a
regular house i mean there's a lot
between
living in a tiny home and a big house um
and if you do own your own home uh you
could
install gray water systems cistern to
capture rain
you can you can model some environmental
technologies that could be then used
widespread in your neighborhood or your
town
uh i think there's things you can do
that could
then those kinds of modalities that can
be replicated to really fix
cities and systemic problems um that's
another
way of going if you are going to choose
to live kind of the house you have now
100 and so i think that they're you know
you can just keep going with this
um but you don't have to live in a
certain type of way you know you
you don't have to live in a tiny place
to have a big impact
right and it shouldn't be driven by
guilt but rather
you know this this aspiration to live
more connected
yeah and you can be minimalist i mean i
i don't live i don't have a big
footprint
uh in terms of where i live but um but
some of that is
is just kind of the circumstances that
you know of of my life
so uh and there's ways to uh correct me
if i'm wrong you probably know more
about this and i probably should know
more about this than i do but
when you are um
uh traveling by air you can you can
purchase
carbon assets or you can find a way to
do that travel in a carbon neutral way
you can
[Music]
you